bootleg cab podcast man special guests
in here my guy he's here he's the
hottest man on the internet am I I mean
I'll take it in more than one way item
22. bootleg Kev how you doing I'm good
man I can't complain brother it's so
crazy so yesterday we're in my studio
and I was like oh yeah adam22 is coming
on tomorrow I told uh my producer and
there was like this random white dude in
the studio
and he was like oh that's the guy right
who like let the dude his wife
and I was like yeah and he asked he was
like wait you don't know who Adams 22 is
like otherwise he's like no like what
does he do yeah it does feel like that
there's a lot of people who just found
out about me from this which is it's
good for your business yeah I can't
complain how is the metrics changed in
terms of like just just like on a basic
level like let's say just your IG
on since all this happened with with
Lena your wife I think I might have
gained like 50 000 followers on on
Instagram in like 60 or 70 on Twitter so
just obviously that doesn't like matter
that much but it is kind of indicative
of oh okay there's a lot of new eyeballs
on me I'm curious too because like I've
seen obviously I I just saw I think I
just saw something on Tick Tock Elena on
why you guys chose Jason love okay
um how long was you guys get married
yeah beautiful wedding was in Italy yeah
I love it looked crazy thank you and
then you guys appeared to have gone on
the most elaborate honeymoon family
vacation ever that is the most baller
[__] that we've ever done and it was
like a month right there was so much
money the nicest hotels ever I was like
just surrounded by Real Deal rich people
and how much would you drop in a month
oh probably six figures six figures on
the honeymoon yeah damn well I look like
it for sure it was crazy
um and then you guys come back and it
feels like this kind of happens not
necessarily right away but it feels like
it almost happens
rather quickly we had been talking about
it basically since the beginning of the
year around January we did like a tick
tock with Jason love while we were at
the AVN I remember seeing that yeah and
it went crazy just us joking around
about the idea of her sleeping with a
guy so we already kind of had the idea
in our head and we had an idea of like
oh this is going to be viral like really
viral like this this might be just the
thing we need to sort of switch things
up and get rid get people really really
excited about it but we definitely
didn't know to what extent it was gonna
explode because she had a dollar amount
in her head that she told me at one
point and she has to date made like 50
50 times that the dollar amount meaning
how much money she thinks she would make
if she were to do that clip and yes and
then it's like
that times 50. whoa yeah like it was so
much bigger than we ever would have
dreamed well this is what I was gonna
say because like I would say this dude
like it feels like you guys really
planned this out in such a meticulous
way
and I feel like you've done such a great
job of like mastering the virality of
this moment I feel like I get
being a public Persona a lot more than I
ever did before and I feel like I get
going viral a lot more I feel a lot I I
it's ironic I feel like this gigantic
man putting in my really kind of like
helped me to like ReDiscover my voice
because I feel like so much less scared
or intimidated or or worried about what
I say on camera or whatever like after
the insanity of all this it just feels
like oh like you could say whatever you
want at this point yeah like oh the
Soulja Boy said something about me on
live all right I'm gonna go off on
Soulja Boy like oh Cowboy said some lame
[__] about me on podcast I'm gonna go
off on Cowboy like I'm just not worried
and it's like even even just like my
Instagram comments I was always kind of
combing that [__] and just like
restricting people who would say rude or
whatever and at a certain point during
all this it just became like okay what's
the point of even looking at dude who
cares yeah I used to like wake up and
search my name on Twitter yeah I've done
it yeah that is not happening anymore
yeah you can't do it anymore it's over
now it's over yeah it's pretty yeah it's
crazy well I was gonna say like when you
guys sat down and said okay we're gonna
do this did you map out the promo did
you map out okay we're gonna do this
this and this leading up to it and then
afterwards we're gonna do this this and
that like how much of like some of the
content we saw was like absolutely
planned because a lot of it felt like I
was like oh you're like you were you're
really turning up and like leaning into
a lot of things most of it wasn't like
planned plan like in advance it was
mostly just me and her kind of just
talking about it and rolling with the
punches and just seeing what happened
and like you know you know like I I had
uh okay it was like there was one Monday
where Jason love did an interview a
couple weeks ago and basically was like
kind of talking spicy being a little bit
disrespectful this was not planned this
was just him kind of not knowing how to
act right knowing how to deal with the
the spotlight you know and I'm not gonna
lie like when I first seen it I had like
a day where I was kind of thinking about
it and I was annoyed and then like as I
was going to bed that night I just
pictured in my head me making a tick
tock in which I threatened him and
blacklisted him from my wife's vagina
okay and I was just laying in bed by
myself just laughing so hard thinking
about the idea of me making this Tick
Tock and then I woke up the next morning
and I made The Tick Tock and I got like
five million views and I and I don't
know it's it's kind of been that over
and over and over where it's like oh
like you have no reason to like get
emotionally involved in this or whatever
you can just [__] with people and troll
people and the end result is that people
don't really know what was real and what
wasn't real because there was like
little parts of it yeah nobody respected
a lot of trolling like a lot of like you
know like you said like like that video
you're talking about like when you're
like you're banned from L.A how about
that you're bad for my wife's vagina
yeah it was just like okay all right
well uh but but it but like you said it
worked and like I would also want to
like because obviously
is there has there has there been any
real world
complications because we I mean I I
don't believe I mean anything we see on
the internet I don't really look too
much into because you've kind of
mastered the internet right right has
there been an actual any like real world
complications in terms of
the attention like has it made it harder
for Linda to do certain stuff how does
her family feel about everything like is
I mean our families are really cool
about it in the sense that our families
have never mentioned the porn thing to
either of us ever ever wait wait wait
never never like
like your whole time being together it's
never gotten brought up I'll hear about
some [__] here and there like I'll hear
about oh my mom said something to my
sister about it and like asked her a
question about like oh why is Adam on
the cover of this you know website or
like why did why did the New York Post
post about Adam buying a Lamborghini
which is not not real you know a lot of
even my close friends thought that there
like a few people have come over my
house and been like where you keep the
Lamborghini I'm like oh yeah that video
well I wasn't gonna say that because you
would hit me and you were like hey man
you got some prop money
because I was gonna give her like 100
Grand or 200 Grand at the same time but
I couldn't find any prop money yet
um but yeah no our families just don't
mention it they're just kind of too
polite it's kind of like the elephant in
the room a little like when you go over
to the Armenian get-togethers it doesn't
get brought up at all no wow which is
crazy right like they just they're too
polite which thank God because I don't
want to [__] talk about that [__]
with them oh that's I'm just gonna one
word answer the [__] out of them if they
did try to bring it up to me or whatever
I'm just gonna laugh and roll with it
but yeah so there really hasn't been
anything too like like I mean obviously
you guys I mean you've always been kind
of famous like in the last seven years
eight years right it's been what 2015-16
is when you really started yeah I mean I
started November in 2015 and even before
that I had like 10 years of being this
very prominent BMX personality which
kind of like allowed me to get used to
but it's safe to say like six straight
years you've been kind of like a thing
on the you know where like my kid knows
who you are you know like looks like it
but I would say now it's different right
definitely feels like we hit like a
different level of that and even today
we announced that we're doing this thing
that's like a a YouTube slash only fans
live stream where basically we're gonna
do a big 10 person podcast with a bunch
of porn stars and then in the other room
we haven't only fans live stream going
at the same time so it's basically going
to be like an orgy with a big group of
people and they're just swapping kind of
going back and forth in and out and like
the comments like like it just feels
like there's so much more attention on
everything that we do porn wise now but
at the the same time we also just have
this massive wave of hate with
everything we do too but like on Twitter
or Tick Tock getting comments and
getting hate is like one of the biggest
things that makes your [__] viral get
promoted so like I have random uh
Kendama Clips on my Tick Tock now that
have like three million views just
because like a couple thousand people
stopped in to say like haha you're a
cook or you know you're a piece of [__]
or you're you're a terrible parent or
whatever and I'm like okay well if I if
all I have to deal with is this and you
guys are going to make everything I do
go viral okay
there are certain things that are like
can you explain to me some of the
unwritten rules or code of the porn game
because you had shared some information
that we won't talk about off camera the
last time I saw you some details about
your video or Lena's video rather would
Jason love that we won't talk about but
there is a code right like and and I
think you said that Jason love maybe
broke the code a little I mean nobody
has ever explicitly told me that there's
a Code but I definitely feel like
there's an expectation that you keep it
a little bit gangster in terms of the
whole porn thing because if you're on
set you're going to see a lot of weird
[__] you know you're going to see dudes
having to jerk their dick off for 45
minutes to get hard you're gonna see
guys having a pop viagara to get hard
you're going to see you know girls who
have over there on their periods so they
have to go and like shove some [__]
sponge thing in there and to clean out
whatever kind of stuff might be in there
there's all kinds of [__] and like I
realize this because I like the one time
I did a anal threesome with Riley Reed
and my girl back in the day in our
backyard which is kind of hard to
imagine now we probably wouldn't do that
these days since we have like a family
and everything but you know there was
some some leakage some [__] flying you
know it's happened and you know I had a
turret on my knee at one point and stuff
and then I went on the podcast that week
and I just talked about it and my girl
had to tell me like yo like I don't
think girls are gonna necessarily want
to do anal threesomes with us if you're
just going to be airing out the grossest
things that happened and I was like that
is a really good point and so anything
like messy that happens on set I feel
like it's kind of
our responsibility to not talk about it
if a dude can't get hard it's like we're
not going to clown them we're just going
to kind of ignore it to me also probably
within the porn guy's code should be
like you don't like you know especially
if a [__] well-known dude like me is
gonna let you [__] their wife on camera
for porn content you should probably not
be critical of him in any way or you
might be respectful yeah you know don't
do this weird like dick comparison thing
or whatever even though obviously yeah
you have a huge hog but it's like you
just don't need to say that and I feel
like now if we shoot with any more guys
that will be very much a conversation
it's like okay this is the this is the
way that we can talk about this and this
is what we can and we need this you know
to stay on the same page in terms of all
this but I feel like he he got a lot of
hate for maybe not beating it up right
and that I I guess he probably had never
dealt with that before so he was
probably trying to compensate for that
by clarifying and like on your end
you're probably like thank you
I mean thanks for not like yeah you've
seen like some of these [__] scenes
This Guy's in he's [__] you know and
I thought about that after like oh wow
like I kind of got off easy there
because you know I didn't really think
about what kind of sex they were going
to be having beforehand and the the
scene that they did was very much like
very you know a a an easy entry point
for me in the sense that it was not some
Brian Gosling Hot Shot Hot Shot hookups
or whatever the [__] that is it's just
like the most aggressive type of porn
obviously so yeah I mean I guess he he
did kind of do me a favor in that regret
shout out to uh is he gonna come on the
podcast I don't know I don't know what
the [__] he's doing I heard he like flew
to Toronto to do six Buzz so who knows
what they're gonna ask him oh he's just
he's just he's he's probably this
probably raised his profile to like a I
mean he was already a pretty popular guy
I'm sure yeah but the weird thing in
porn is like you could be really popular
in porn and then you're still kind of
like a regular person to most people
right especially if you're a dude yeah
oh especially if you're a dude and even
like you know sometimes I think about
that like I can't get a little baby
interview I can't get a cardi interview
or Uzi vert interview but it's no
problem for me to get a savannah Bond
piece of content or Angela White or all
these like super huge girls are much
more approachable and like you know
humble than the top rappers you know
what um what is the like expectation now
moving forward is this is are you guys
gonna make her doing the dude scene a
regular thing we're definitely gonna do
more of it but I would say like the
frequency is probably the thing that's
kind of Up For Debate that we're still
kind of figuring out and like you know
there's some stuff that I really don't
mind at all like like I probably would
have been real nervous about it before
but like me [__] her with another guy
I don't really like feel any type of way
about that anymore like that's no
problem like I'll definitely do that
would you do the would you do the DP
yeah I feel like that's on the bucket
list but then that's like a dick on dick
yeah and you know it's like I'm not
gonna [__] a dude Kev listen I don't
want you to [__] do but if you're
gonna do the DP there's no way that your
guys's dicks don't touch or ball slap or
just you're crossing swords I gotta do
it one time before I die okay and you
might I mean you gotta do I mean
obviously you're married so it's got to
be with you my leg bumps another dude's
leg it's like whatever we all been in
the gym locker room before or whatever
but also like I don't know like it's got
to be a homie I think it's got to be
something I'm like real cool with would
you ever do anything with the transporn
star no
even if it was like [__] your wife
with a trans porn star
I don't feel like I want to turn our sex
life into a culture War thing you know
if I just
I'm not trying to like prove my wokeness
or anything and I [__] with a lot of
trans uh women and stuff like have had a
lot of them on the podcast I had Emma
Rose on the podcast I think I saw a
little bit of the uh you guys did like a
um a panel right it was like yeah yeah
and I got to meet a lot of really cool
trans people in that situation and
everything but my whole thing is like
I'm not really trying to do anything on
camera for money that I wouldn't want in
my private life as well yeah so like I
don't you know and even like I'll like
I'm not personally really like Mega
attracted to a BBW that's like 400
pounds right would I maybe do it on
camera like maybe yeah like that doesn't
so bad would you pop a Bluetooth
I might have to pop something I don't
know yeah my papa energy drink my papa's
C4 let's not give them any free [__]
publicity there all right that's why I
have their logo turned away from them
this guy's over here got the Celsius on
the floor
man we're over here drinking [__]
Energy Drinks like a couple of real
white guys like a couple of real Arizona
and New Hampshire white boys right
oh [__] now you know the one thing I
would say is like
I I've you know I have for whatever
reason I think people think we're like a
lot like we're cool like I think me and
you are cool I think we're friends you
know like but
I have so many people in my life that
came to me like I'm like your
representative and they're like yo son
what's up with your boy and I'm like at
the end of the day
this guy's a professional porn star
who's [__] however many hundreds of
women since he's been in his
relationship to me it's not that big of
a deal right
that she gets one yeah I mean it is
weird because it's like yeah I have
[__] all these chicks with her and
nobody really like ever made a big deal
about it like you know and it's a double
standard thing and it's also kind of
because we're like we're in hip-hop
culture and it I think that's where it
kind of like people are like yo like
bruh like yeah and I expected like
hip-hop to have strong opinions about it
but I didn't really expect there to be
like 20 bar stool articles and you know
to have like Andrew Tate Logan Paul all
these people like discussing it in depth
on their podcast and [__] you know I
didn't expect to have everyone in the
whole world having conversations about
it which that surprised me there was I I
want to say I saw an old interview clip
it might have been when you were on
flagrant where you had pretty much I
could be uh you're right yeah I shut the
door on it you pretty much shut the door
hard on like what changed which is weird
because maybe a year before that I
remember I went on academics's podcast
and he asked if I would ever do a
threesome with another dude and my girl
and I basically like left the door open
for it and was just kind of like you
know yeah I would be open to it like I
would be interested in it I didn't say
that I was gonna do it but I said I'd be
open to the idea and I remember even at
that time just me suggesting that I
would maybe be down for it was so viral
and such a big thing and academics
freaked out and could not believe that I
was acknowledging it and even on Vlad
there was a clip I saw like because I I
talked on interviews so much that I
forget what I say and but I'm glad I
said the same thing I said like
I would consider it you know and so yeah
like the clipping went viral though was
me saying that I definitely wouldn't do
it which is pretty funny but uh yeah I
mean what changed is basically just me
getting a little bit more open-minded as
time went by and like you know me and
her talked about like swinging off
camera and like hooking up with like a
different couple together or something
like that take a Friday night go out on
the town get a hotel room something like
that maybe but then we were like well if
we're ever gonna do that like we
probably should film it and if we're
gonna we should make some money yeah you
should probably like make your first
scene with another guy like a big
blowout thing pause
The Swinging world is crazy my cousin
and his ex-wife were swingers when I was
growing up okay and I'd be at his house
and the [__] would just be going down
bruh I'd be like 14 15 with all my
homies from school and we'd be watching
his wife [__] Chomp down on another
chick you'd be watching it oh yeah 14.
he literally my cousin literally to be
like hey you guys go outside and just
I'll leave the door I'll leave the
window cracked wow shout out to James
James I feel like you have a duty if
you're living that lifestyle to not have
uh 14 year olds around well it was yeah
yeah my cousin James was like I think he
was like 21 at the time so it was we
were we were like more friends than like
he was like my OG but they were they
were they'd go to these like uh Retreats
and they would go to these Resorts and
like yeah it's like a thing bro like I
mean Kazumi sent me a link to a book
about polyamorous relationships the
because I've never read about it or
research that or even really thought
about it because me and my girl are not
Polly in that sense like we just do porn
with other people we've do it for
Content yeah and even like you know we
haven't hooked up with another girl off
camera in probably like three four years
at this point so it's definitely like
not something I'm super familiar with
we've just been doing it for Content but
you know even like my girl yesterday
like we were on the Jason Lee podcast
and she just kind of said like yeah you
know if you were on a trip and you ended
up [__] some girl as long as you told
me like or or as long as you were safe
about it I don't think I would really
care that much I'm like wow like you're
you're Progressive your mind is changing
a bit because I remember when me and her
first got in the relationship she made
it very clear like you're on tour you're
on like if you're on the road yeah [__]
around but yeah she was like I'm not
really [__] with that anymore like I
could get away with it for the first
year or two of our relationship but then
at some point she's like I'm not [__]
with that I'm Gonna Leave You if you
just [__] somebody that's cheating right
yeah like it's actual cheating you know
but like apparently she's kind of
softened up on that a bit although I
don't really trust these hoes enough to
even do that I don't want to be in a
hotel room alone with a girl yeah you
know you'd be on [__] Reddit with
your ass out I don't trust these [__]
at all not even that they're just gonna
lie they're gonna say that I did
something you know oh yeah especially
with you bro yeah exactly yeah yeah I
like doing with her because then I have
a guardian who's actually like observing
it and nobody's able to ever to ever and
that's why even if I was gonna shoot
porn just me and another girl I would
definitely have like a real filmer so at
least I could have you have a witness
yeah
um you mentioned earlier that like there
was a certain point in time where
you said Uzi Carter you're not getting
these interviews I remember that really
nobody is but well you're right right
yeah um that's that's a fair point like
big boy I'll probably get cardi B
um oh I meant Playboy cardi but yeah oh
cardi well yeah
you never did Playboy cardi ever he came
to the studio and stuff uh when we were
still downtown and like I remember I
even had a conversation with him at a
concert and or a show rather in like
2015 2016 where I was like bro let's do
this interview and I remember he was
like I ain't trying to do no long [__]
I'll do a 20 minute joint I did like a
20 minute interview with him at the
radio station and it was horrible it was
horrible it's on YouTube it was like
talking to like a piece of drywall or
something if you watched that big boy
interview he did it was [__] the
worst thing ever but yeah I mean like
it's always weird with [__] like that
where it's like [__] if I just tried a
little bit harder I could have a Playboy
Card interview from 2016. that's [__]
crazy but I probably have like [__]
30 million views or something I probably
did like you know a million other
interviews that were easier to get
instead of working on that one that was
like well I was gonna say like obviously
you have a huge platform you still have
a very important platform but there was
an era in which your platform was
literally you had a [__] record deal
your platform was like a career maker
for up-and-coming artists because in
like 2016 there were so few options for
an artist like the perfect example of it
is six nine like I met six nine in 2017
or some [__] and then he proceeded to
harass the [__] out of me for like six
months or eight months or some [__]
trying to get an interview and then
finally he did the song with trippy
which I felt was like oh okay he's
actually becoming a real thing so I did
the interview with him but if that was
his first like song that really like
actually did yeah every song yeah yeah
and uh but but I remember I showed that
to Hell Rel and he wasn't feeling it at
the time but uh you know
six nine had to go to somebody like me
to try to get an interview where I was
like even right now in New York I can
think of like eight different platforms
that he could go [__] with if you're on
the radar or yeah yeah it's like there's
so many different people that you could
[__] with whereas now like if I I I I
get a lot of hate for like oh you
changed your [__] up and didn't just
keep doing underground artist interviews
what I think people don't realize is
that no jumper as a business would never
have lasted in the long run if I just
kept doing only underground rapper
interviews like building out casts and
hosts and expanding into doing
interviews with Comedians and YouTubers
and porn stars and whoever like I needed
to do all that [__] in order to like
keep the boat afloat you know because
the the media space just became so
flooded so fast and even especially now
where everybody wants to get paid for
interviews and [__] I mean like like in
terms of like really ambitious ones no
for sure I'm not sure tried to crack me
for like 10 grand and I laughed I
literally said LOL I'll pass
so what that is amazing yeah no I get
hit with that all the time when people
want five or ten Grand who are like
having no business asking for money and
I'm just like wow the game is [__] up
but I was gonna say like because like
you said like you did you I mean
obviously everyone should evolve and the
business model for you has evolved
um but I remember like even talking to
like
you go back to that 2017-2018 era of no
jumper I remember talking to Sasha who I
think you would were talking to at a
certain point time maybe doing a no
jumper Festival
um you had the single you were you were
so dived in on the music do you remember
was there like a point in time or a
moment that you can kind of point to
where you were like I got to be more
than this if this is gonna really last I
guess I've just always been like doing
everything I could possibly do to try to
keep the brand going and keep the brand
afloat and keep content going and just
figuring out how I could make content on
a regular basis that would do well with
the audience and stuff and so yeah I
mean definitely me getting canceled in
2018 was probably the biggest factor in
terms of like oh now you have some
percentage of artists that are not going
to want to [__] with you because they're
on some workers because they have this
perception of whatever happened because
that's when you lost your deal with
Atlantic right exactly and they in even
like you know the the it might not be
them but like oh they got a manager and
this manager is trying to scare them out
of working with us because of the fact
that
um I've got my own [__] or whatever
so I think that was definitely one
moment where it became like oh you're
gonna have to really figure this [__]
out because maybe your initial game plan
is not is like a little simple it's not
going to work out necessarily if you
just stay focused on just talking to
these underground rappers you know and I
always just I I always was ambitious in
the sense of just wanting to talk to
everybody and sometimes I do go back in
time and think like well what if I had
just interviewed the cool up and coming
rappers and I just kept my [__] super
selective I think the brand in terms of
its coolness might have
persevered like it would have seemed
cooler like more of a honor more
exclusive but at the same time like I
just felt like all of these competitors
springing up all around us and it was
like I just I'm not going to be able to
just do this underground rapper thing
forever because even back in 2018
I could feel that it was slowing down
pretty dramatically in the i in the
sense of like 2015 2016 2017 there was a
new underground rapper every [__] day
it was also like an era of SoundCloud
and Underground Music that was like not
being represented I guess yeah as to
where and and like the IG blogs hadn't
really taken all the way over yeah
yeah I mean now it's just there's just
so much [__] that's it's tough to stand
out and like a lot of the best content
that I do now is just bringing
interesting personalities together
whether it's like the consistent
personalities on the channel or you know
like yesterday I had a Destiny the
twitch streamer with dude and whack 100.
who would have thought them two would
ever sit down like I was so happy I was
just geeked up off that just like I
cannot believe that I just brought these
two [__] together and you know
I'm always just kind of trying to think
of stuff that'll be interesting for
people like that because you just don't
have a new trippy red or a new little
Uzi or a new X to talk to every week you
might get a couple of those a year but
it just doesn't you know they just don't
happen that often yeah it's crazy
because if you think of like a I think
it's something like your early
relationships with guys like x with
juice world you know when juicer was
alive obviously um Legend has there has
there been any of those relationships
that you carried into 2022 or 2023 where
you're like
maybe this person switched up a little
like I can't get this person on my
platform even though I was there with
them at the studio or going you know all
the time yeah like I hear Vlad talk
about that all the time how he was the
first person to Amigos interview yeah
but I feel like that's different though
I feel like it's different though
because I feel like you actually like
were were with these guys like I
remember seeing your Vlogs or you'd be
at shows like you actually were like
hanging out doing drugs with guys but
like all the dudes early on that I had
these strong relationships with are dead
pretty I was gonna say they most of them
passed away yeah and even by the time
you get to like 2018 or 2019 I think of
like oh I did Jack Harlow interview when
he wasn't really on and that I assume
has a lot of views and it's like pretty
sick that I got a jack Harlow interview
early on but it's also like I hung out
with Jack Harlow for five minutes before
we did the interview and then we did the
interview and then I hung out with them
for five minutes afterwards and then I
never saw him again after that right I
just I don't build these crazy strong
friendships with the artists in the way
that I used to which sometimes I look at
people like you who I feel like you do
really good with the relationship side
of things because you're in the clubs
and you're booking these dudes and
you're head with the radio yeah is a
really good way to like maintain these
relationships and stuff and a lot of the
people that I look at that I kind of
have regrets it's like you know how did
I get a suicide boys interview with
millions and millions of views and then
I never went out of my way to hang out
with them ever again after that even
though I got this crazy piece of content
super early in their career and it's
really because I was just focused on the
next thing and like you know sometimes I
regret that I didn't do more to like
nurture relationships but also it just
feels like there's so many potential
relationships because of the fact that I
just interviewed so many [__] people
and I'm so busy that you know that's one
thing I miss about the stores that I
would just have a lot more like casual
interactions with people and it was just
kind of happening All Around Me whereas
now it's like I really kind of rely on
my publicist or dming people to to get
content going yeah because you're also
not like going out like you to at all I
haven't been out like I used to see I
used to see you and your girl at [__]
all the time concerts [__] festivals
whatever oh what's up guys like Saturday
I have a premiere for my BMX brand we
have a BMX DVD coming out and I know I'm
gonna have to be out of the house until
like at least 11 and I'm trying to like
steal myself in preparation for that
because being out of the house until 11
just sounds kind of [__] crazy to me
at this point in my life I just yeah but
then at the same time I'm talking to
Jason Lee yesterday and I'm realizing
this [__] has great
relationships because he's still in the
club and he's he's still out here he's
into his 40s but he's still like
finessing those relationships on a
nightly basis which is something that I
have completely neglected and I should
really probably do more of it I've just
come to the point in my life where any
relationships I already have I I try to
water them you know like plants and I'm
not interested in
going out anymore so if I don't if if
unless it's somebody who I really [__]
with you know or like someone who like
I'm a fan of you know like
I don't care if it's album release party
I don't care I'm tired 2016. like there
was an album release party last night
that I would have went to if I'd have
known but I got hit up last minute like
Bia B is a homegirl like she's cool
right I [__] would be it but I was
already at the crib my wife just cooked
I'm like I already planned a bike ride
exactly yeah and I'm like damn and
especially with the kid thing because it
was like my kids waking me up at six in
the morning yeah my kid is waking me up
at six in the morning and it doesn't
matter if I go to bed at four in the
morning or it doesn't matter you're
getting up at six you're getting up and
it's like and especially like I have a
wife she she will take on all of that
responsibility of taking care of the
kids and everything but I don't feel
like that's fair for me to just put
everything on her and be like nah I'm
sleeping a couple hours later just so
that I can like you know recover from
the fact that I had a fun night last
night because like 2016 if it was a
Friday night this was the era of like
underground warehouse shows in LA and
stuff and there would be like some
random [__] Soulja Boy show in a
warehouse and like the ham on everything
era and I would go and I would see
people I knew and I would stand around
and smoke weed and drink and probably
snort coke and do whatever and just meet
people and just like do this little like
friend collecting thing that you're
doing at a certain point in your life of
just me nice to see you everywhere yeah
and I respect that and there's a certain
point in your career where you have to
do that but also like as soon as I had a
kid it was just like what the [__] am I
doing what were your thoughts on uh
on the whole entire
Drake Elliott Wilson thing and people
saying that Elliot is above doing
running gun interviews and rolling loud
you know I wrestled with that too
because for a long time I would go to
Rolling loud and I would be doing the
thing of standing around and waiting to
get interviews and just trying to you
know just get content yeah and like you
know if you if you get a five minute
conversation with Gunner you just made
your whole trip you know like I went to
you did a young thug one at one of those
yeah and that was the best one that I
ever did and then that's that kind of
killed it for me after that because that
was 2019 and I go to wireless Festival
in London and I get like a 20 minute
Young Thug interview I get like a really
dope juice World Vlog I get Denzel Curry
this is all like in the same day that we
just made like a bunch of fire pieces of
content crazy crazy day crazy day and it
was all because it's in England so
they're not like super they're not
getting pulled in every direction by
their homies there's not a lot of media
and it's not super formal in the sense
that like even young thug has a little
ass like you know like the big as big as
like this table in like the of areas
surrounding it right he's just chilling
like he doesn't have a lot and him there
as opposed to him doing rolling out in
La is a lot different in terms of the
backstage environment who's around him
he's got friends he's got the you know I
remember I went to some random Festival
in Santa Ana like right after that
London one was it the day and night one
yeah and it was just infinitely less
likely that I was going to get any good
content at that you know and like for
somebody like Elliot it's like you
probably remember 2002 he was like the
god of hip-hop media because she was the
editor of double XL and he basically
destroyed the source and he was clicked
up with g in it and Eminem and all this
[__] and I still to this day look at
Elliot I was like just a massive
inspiration in terms of showing me how
it could be done but I Googled it the
other day I think he's like 52 or some
[__] so it is a question of like
does there come a time where you're a
little bit too old or a little bit too
established to be doing the Run and Gun
interviews backstage at rolling loud I
mean I I hope when I'm 52 that I
wouldn't even consider it to be totally
honest I'm 39 now I can still see myself
doing it but I also don't at all so I
don't know I mean like in a perfect
world yeah Elliot Wilson would be like
Jay-Z like where he's just able to like
be this content God and not have to be
in the trenches with the people but at
the same time like you want to be in the
trenches with the people right like
there is an extent to which that's
what's going to keep you young and keep
you in people's minds but I don't really
see myself doing that at 52 but also I
don't I don't judge Elliot for it I feel
like he's still just kind of yeah that's
my thing I think I think it's like it's
like an unfair judgment because I'm sure
he got paid because he was doing
official rolling loud [__] oh it was
four runs it was four rolling loud so
yeah he definitely got a bag for it yeah
and at the end of the day like
everybody's trying to reinvent
themselves like Elliot is he's kind of
gotta I know notice he started
interviewing like a guy like key Glock
which I'm not sure like you know four
years ago he would be interviewing key
clock you know what I'm saying I mean I
haven't watched a lot of Elliot's
interviews over there they're really
good like the Rap Radar podcast is
amazing really okay so I wasn't Drake
one a few years ago I'm not sure I've
seen any since then but like the Drake
one was incredible Flawless like for
sure you actually asked him every single
thing that I could imagine you asking
they're very thorough yeah that was
amazing to me I I but I haven't really
been super tuned in yeah yeah for you
are do you even like care to discover
new music anymore like are you still
like ear to the street type guy or if it
comes across your peripherals and you
like it you'll check it it's weird
because it's like the stuff that I like
which is like the Street Music the drill
music right crazy [__] that stuff yeah
I'm constantly finding out about new
[__] because I had a lot of people in my
life that'll be like check out o51 kiddo
check out Tay Savage check out all this
Chicago [__] or like listen to this new
Bronx drill rapper or whatever so that
stuff it's super easy for me to stay on
top of you know you're talking about Bia
I know she's popular I don't think I've
ever heard her I'm never gonna like go
listen to an R B artist or like a girl
rapper or whatever realistically like
it's just you don't like r b no no no no
well you just got excited genuine
followed you well that's genuine
so you listen to genuine growing up or
are you more like a januides the guy who
fell off stage come on like that that
comes from the era of me going home from
from school and watching TRL and like
just genuine was on whatever they're
playing right you're watching it like I
I there's a lot of Backstreet Boys songs
that I know every word too unfortunately
that like I'm just never gonna I'm never
gonna see a bunch of you know uh who's
was sort of the K-Pop group BTS
single BTS I love R B I'm r b hits I
love r b but yeah BTS I I couldn't tell
you I keep thinking about because like
the last couple of days I've just been
listening to like all of Dirk's albums
and every single album it's like I could
kind of cut it in half and take all the
soft [__] I was gonna say do you
um are you a big Dirk fan I am a big
Dirk fan okay yeah yeah but if he's
rapping about eyelashes and [__] you
know you want to hear that [__]
whatever no I want to hear kill your Ops
like that's what I'm trying to and I'm
not proud of that it's just like I like
the aggressive songs have are always the
songs that I like yeah yeah you had a
pretty uh dope Derek interview what was
that like 2018 yeah which I didn't like
I knew it was a good interview to get
but it definitely didn't feel like he
was going to be well I think as big as
he is now yeah I think Dirk had like I
think Dirk's got one of those careers
that's like very unique because
he he was on Def Jam forever he was and
like he's evolved into something that
I'm not sure I would have get like you
said in 2018 if somebody would have told
you he's like one of the biggest rappers
in the world you'd been like yeah
I didn't know I didn't I didn't see it
happening but it happens all the time
that there's like artists that I'll
interview and I think they're just super
whatever or I think they're they're good
but like oh yeah he's got a little C to
potential but if I was a betting man and
you were like I would want 101 odds if I
was going to bet 100 bucks on them you
know which is but sometimes dudes just
really go for it and really work their
ass off or or their their sound it just
takes people a while to catch up to
their sound you know do you regret you
know because I remember very vividly you
were waving the little pump flag harder
than any rapper I think I've ever seen
you wave a flag for at a certain point
in time I think I remember when you
first went on The Breakfast Club
Breakfast Club you didn't no ever no
well there was an interview
was it just you and Charlemagne I
interviewed him at one point yeah and I
went on the brilliant idiots one time it
was brilliant idiots it was brilliant
idiots okay yeah so when you went on
brilliant idiots I think I remember you
kind of [__] on Rick Ross a little
uh I think they asked me what I thought
of the new Rick Ross album and you were
like I don't [__] care I'm listening
to a little pump or some [__] yeah I
mean that's just really like there's
just artists who I like and then a
certain point once they're on like album
Number Eight I'm just not well I was
gonna say there was like you were kind
of like partially the face of like that
SoundCloud era and you were also very
anti
uh a lot of the other [__] I think I got
a lot of the the a lot of that
reputation for being like
anti-traditional hip-hop just because of
the fact that I was like the adult in
the room when Lil pump and smoke prep
were chanting [__] J Cole even though I
don't think I ever I don't think I ever
said [__] J Cole you know like I I was
not invested in it like that and I've
always been able to appreciate you know
more traditional hip-hop and everything
but yeah I mean that was just I was
around the SoundCloud wave like before
them I was around all these like sesh
Hollow Waterboys dudes and like all the
GBC [__] and then I you know I met I met
Lil pump at a show in Florida that like
ski mask played and like a few other
people and yeah we just hit it up hit it
off on some cool [__] we went on that
tour together and then I you know I went
to a few of his shows after that and
stuff but yeah I mean sometimes when I
think back on that I'm like you're a
grown ass man just really hanging out
with like a 16 year old I was gonna say
you you you in in like fast forward you
have gotten a lot of recent criticism
for maybe that tour and like maybe some
of the stuff that went down on the Torah
pump do you regret any of that tour or
do you think any of that criticism
criticism is fair I mean we were just
hanging out doing zams and like I mean
yeah there's a lot of stuff listen in
retrospect a grown man doing zans with a
child is kind of crazy yeah but that was
just like my little homie at the time
like I didn't I I never thought of it
like that because that's for sure I've
been a BMX dude my whole life and I've
been getting you know smoking weed and
drinking and hanging out at the skate
park and yeah all this [__] and I never
had any like level of scrutiny of what I
was doing so it never really occurred to
me and it's not like I was like getting
drugs for them it's like right no like
they had drugs and like sometimes pump
or smoke prep would like hand me a Xanax
and or pour me some lean and I'm like
okay sure yeah you know what would be
your uh thoughts on why you think those
two guys did not live up to their
potential and I guess quote unquote fell
off because I mean it looked like
smokepurp was with Travis this and pump
was the biggest guy on the [__]
planet you know
part of me you know I got no ill will
towards either of them I still think
that they both potentially you know have
it in them but I feel like everyone's
one hit away that's what I'm saying like
and at a certain point the low pump
thing was just so big that it's like
they the people couldn't help but turn
against him at a certain point once like
they loved the meme they loved the idea
of him they loved the the hilarity of of
pump and then at a certain point they
just turned away from him because maybe
the music didn't evolve or keep changing
or whatever and uh I don't know I mean
you see it happen on people all the time
like it happened to the baby they're
doing it's a little baby right now but
guess what the baby caught a record and
it's kind of back a little I I I don't
doubt for a minute that the biggest
something right now yeah because he's a
smart older guy who really like has
studied the music game for a long time
and that's why I don't count Lil pump or
perp out because I feel like I think all
they need to do is just like come up
with a sound make up project that
encompasses that sound and all of a
sudden those same people are hating on
them will be like those those same
people are always trying to catch a wave
or like figure out something new or
different to be into will be like
actually this little pump album's really
good and then that'll be the meme and I
mean they just did it with little yachty
when he put out the [__] Tame Impala
type album exactly and or but like bro
you see the way that they're trying to
take little baby down right now yeah
because he put out a record they hate
the record they hated his last album
whatever and so and then the tour dates
are getting canceled and now they're
looking for any little thing that they
can use to put together the narrative
that little baby is a loser even though
a little baby like probably literally
has like you know 50 million dollars or
100 million dollars or some [__] like
he's living a great life if anything
like I saw ack posted a clip of like
baby making that song in the studio and
there's all these homies in the in the
studio and they're all nodding their
head and like acting like they're really
into it and then that song comes out and
Twitter just immediately declares it the
worst song ever and but that's what it's
like to be a superstar nobody wants to
tell you that your [__] sucks and you
just are running around the world
picking up you know fifty thousand
dollars for a show hundred thousand
dollars for a show and then all of a
sudden you put out a song and you just
get this reality check that like oh
there's a lot of people that are not
already decided on the fact that they
love you and they're gonna [__] on you
and they're gonna hate you and you know
but somebody like a little baby like I
would say the same thing as pump and
purp like
yeah yeah a little baby's gonna be all
right gotta stop the interview and say
about our good Folks at Odd Socks baby
yeah shout out to odd talks now this is
what I love about odd stocks one their
family we love them but also they have
the most comfortable socks in the
[__] world all right now look they
got the craziest licenses you see the
Jolly Rancher these are actually fly's
[__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the odd Sox Basics now these
are just the basic socks so these are in
my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd Sox basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shout out to the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps uh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview I was
gonna say you had a couple of you have
in your store back in the day resulted
in some cool [__] one obviously I think
the last hurray was kind of
a gun in my face well I was gonna say
when when X passed away and you guys
pretty much shut
that was crazy but then the thing that
actually made us like basically leave
the block was when I got the gun in my
face that seemed like that kind of like
killed the vibe and you know all of a
sudden I didn't want to be there the
same way I needed security around me
whenever I was there everybody's got
guns everybody's just like on a very
different level because we were hanging
out all the [__] time with no guns
around for years there and then all of a
sudden one kid pulls up back and crazy
and that just kind of really changed the
flavor of the block
um I was gonna say though like you had a
dope interaction with J Cole where he
just fell through randomly and Shout Out
Sasha who he just named he's the one who
basically lined that up shout out to
Sasha good guy uh and then um I think
about MGK Kevin came and bought a bike
at your store did he yeah that's
something that him and I talked about
because he was like you know I bought a
bike from that store really and he said
that's why he doesn't understand why
because I guess you were [__] on him
you guys have this like you guys had
like a little I remember real dude I
never knew who why he had an issue with
me aside for like the only things I
could think of probably said something
that he saw he's a sensitive guy yeah I
mean I'm sure you said something about
him yeah I mean I don't like his rap
like all his rap records back in the day
I I remember like he put a record out
and I listened to it and I said it was
garbage and I never really bought a bike
from me though so it's funny because
yeah because him and I because you know
I'm real cool with cows and and we were
talking and I was like you know Adam
like I can connect you Adam he's a good
because you know I don't know if you
remember I put you on the phone with
Russ
oh yeah you did and I we had like a
conversation that I always think about
that because I had a conversation
thinking that we were on air
we weren't I know right but I was having
the conversation like I was trying to
film it yeah but then I realized after
like oh that wasn't on air like the only
people who know about that conversation
are me Russ and Kev whereas I was
speaking as if I had the whole world
listening to me but damn that's crazy
that you had that conversation with MGK
because I never gotten that's what he
told me he was like it's crazy because
actually went out of my way to make sure
when I bought a bike I bought it from
his store just to kind of keep the money
within like the culture type [__] I
don't think anybody ever told me like at
the store that that happened it's
possible that I know he said he bought a
bike he's like I bought a bike from from
his spot I literally went out of my way
to go buy the bike somebody should have
told me yeah because I look at all that
like oh why do I have problems with MGK
like why why was he so mad at me it's
really just for me like saying I didn't
like his music at a certain point or
like making fun of him and I mean I
really am not like a big fan of his
music but also like I'm sure me and him
would get along all right and like I
remember uh somebody told me that he
lives near me And so I've had the
thought multiple times while I'm doing
cardio just walking around the
neighborhood just thinking like imagine
I just saw MGK and we just had to fight
in the front yard like that would be
crazy
because like if he came up to me on some
crazy [__] I guess I'm just gonna fight
him even though that's not normally an
option for right I'm not normally gonna
like I think both both of you guys are
too rich for that to happen I would
think so as well but I mean you've seen
him punch some guy at the fair the other
day I got nothing against him yeah but I
mean that was I think that was more I
mean his lady was nearby yeah I I you
know yeah you got to kind of hold your
chick down and yeah but somebody said
some crazy [__] to her and then he had
his security right there for me if
somebody said something crazy to us to
my girl I'm gonna be like security get
him like I'm paying you for a reason but
he's had security for so long
he's a hot head you know like like I've
seen like Kelsey you know he's a good
dude but yeah you guys I'm sure one day
we'll have a conversation or you'll be
jogging and he'll honk at you from a
pink G wagon I'm down or something like
that I would have a conversation with
him yeah I would just say the F the [__]
Russ era obviously all that kind of that
was that the only time you actually had
an artist physically do harm to you or
is there anything we never heard about
well the Russ didn't doing it it was his
guy right yeah I was just like at the
nail salon around the corner from my
store at the time and I remember it was
some kind of like goth boy click event
or some [__] like Jesus that sounds like
that sounds like a terrible thing so
basically you have like a shitload of
zand out goth kids hanging out at the
store right and so I dip off at one
point I go around the corner to the to
the the nail salon and I'm getting my
nails done and I thought oh I'm gonna
put my hood up and I'm gonna face away
from the door so that nobody can tell
it's me not a great idea didn't see
these guys coming and then I just hear
at one point Adam 22. wow get punched on
the side of the head and I like fall
down for a second like I think you hit
me one more time and then I jump up and
by the time I jump up they're out and
you didn't even realize it was connected
to Russ until later right I didn't
realize it was connected to a rust until
like a year later when academics was on
live stream with them and Russ said
something like yeah that full Adam 22
got touched too but like it was breaking
up on the recording of the stream but AK
knew what he said so act told me he goes
this is what Russ said and immediately
Clicks in my head like oh my God the
Nigerians because Russ is always talking
about his Nigerian homies and [__] and
I'm like oh my God those guys were
Nigerian like I got beat up by a couple
of Nigerians that Rush sent through and
so then all of a sudden it made sense
and I remember I sat on it and thought
about it for a couple days and then one
day I was like you know what I might as
well just use the [__] for some clouds
so I just go on Twitter and start being
like hey [__] Russ
hey I feel like I feel like his um
campaign of beating up rappers that talk
[__] it worked right because nobody says
it no more and I feel like people now
are like yo maybe Russ was onto
something when it came to being
independent and like owning your Masters
and not getting [__] by labels right I
mean what I will say is that Russ
definitely like didn't do himself any
favors around that time he was just
saying a bunch of wild ass [__] and just
kind of disrespecting a lot of people
yeah I mean he had that t-shirt
um that stands out when he dissed all
the Atlanta producers or whatever and I
remember Southside was going crazy on
him like he made a lot of weird
decisions around that time now that
being said I and the reason why I kind
of let it go and just decided like all
right I'm gonna just be cool with Russ
when you initiated the conversation is
because Russ brought it up to me that
there was a lot of tweets that I didn't
remember probably because I was zand the
[__] out just like his T-shirt said
where I was basically like really
roasting this [__] and I don't
do that now like I'm not gonna just use
like a rapper as a punchline like in the
way that I was doing there where I was
really like treating him like he wasn't
a human being you know which to me I
don't I don't approve of that to condone
that I feel like you should approach
everybody as as a person and you know
try to engage with the actual ideas that
they're putting out there now if I had
had some angry tweets where I said Russ
doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about with these Atlanta producers or
actually Xanax is the best how dare you
insult Xanax right then that's fair like
that's me having an opinion right but me
just like clowning him and just treating
them like a joke I don't really condone
that so I have to even though obviously
I don't condone you know him sending
people to beat my house either but I do
respect that you gotta respect the
shooter at the end of the day or the
puncher you can't dictate how people
react to disrespect yeah and I shouldn't
have been lacking anyway it should have
been lacking because man you imagine
another version of that story where I
pull out the thing and just and then you
smoke two random dudes and you're like
and you find out a year later it's not
gonna take a year the cops are going to
go through their phone and be like oh
[__] Russ sent these guys to do this and
then I mean that's the alternate like
realistically that's how that story
would probably play out today so I'm
kind of thankful that I learned that
lesson early on
um
how
look I I think you and I were texting
early on when the whole uh
departure split of no jumper happened
because I'm real real tight with ad and
I've become cool with t-real um over the
last year or so
um
but I remember just hitting you and
being like this was because I came on
the
show the day after you fired Lush okay
and uh I didn't really understand
what I was walking into I guess to the
fully because I heard you say that on
another show yeah you really didn't get
one I didn't understand like the whole
gravity of what was happening right so
like
um
yeah it was [__] uh but you that that
day was crazy because I remember
coming out of the room because you have
multiple content rooms and seeing the
dude who uh went on the stream that same
day and like tried to air you out for
the old 2018 [__] like I saw him coming
in really wow yeah that was the same day
so you so he was there like I remember
seeing him come in and then I think he
walked over to the stream room and then
me and you took a pic and then I left
but I remember like it was later on that
day or maybe it was it was I think and I
remember just being like oh [__] but you
were going through man bro yeah it was
wild I mean it's cut and I remember
hitting you like hey bro he's like stay
strong but it is weird too because I
feel like that would happen to me now
and I wouldn't give a [__] I mean that
wasn't very long ago right so like at
the end of the day like
I've never really
seen I mean everybody is like yo it's
over for this guy we're not we're not
going on a show he's a clown [__]
he's a you know [__] pedo whatever
the [__] like it was like all this [__]
just getting thrown at the [__] house
at the same time yeah
how was your mental
being and like what was the low for you
just in terms of dealing with that I
mean at that time it was rough because
it was like I just felt like oh
I put years of hard work into like
nurturing these guys as talent and then
they just kind of like turned their back
on me as soon as it's convenient for
them so that was kind of tough to accept
but then at the same time you know just
having the internet in general just
attacking me and even that was like one
thing but dude like it seems so silly
but around that same time there was a
clip of me doing an interview with snico
where we were like having this very
sarcastic conversation about how
disgusting vaginas are like really
anybody who knows me or him would be
able to tell that it was a trolling ass
conversation and that when I was saying
that like penises are so much better
than vaginas you just splash a little
bit of puddle water on it and it's clean
whereas a vagina is an open intricate
this is like a version of like a a joke
that I've basically like been telling
like my whole life thing about how dicks
are better than vaginas whatever but
like oh my God like thousands of porn
chicks just using that clip as an
opportunity to act as if I genuinely
hate vaginas and you know it's just like
a lot of that [__] at all at the same
time just it kind of just unloaded on me
and yeah it was really really hard for
me at that time and then I went on the
honeymoon and I kind of like got my mind
right while I was off doing that because
all this is happening right before your
wedding yeah terrible timing very very
very stressful for my girl although then
we we go and do the wedding
and it's like
the perfect wedding it was like so good
everything went so smoothly and then it
made me and her feel like well why the
[__] were we so stressed out about the
wedding and the lead up to all this like
on account of all that other [__] you
know did you like uh I mean are you like
a therapy guy I do I had a therapist for
like three years now and I very much
appreciate her and uh she gives me a
very nice space in which I can kind of
err out everything that uh I'm going
through emotionally sometimes it feels
like my therapist and I is like the one
podcast I do a week that nobody ever
gets to hear right you just like working
through [__] you know
um but yeah she definitely helped helped
talk me through all that stuff and at
any point in time
you've already made your money you're
paid you're doing well plug talks
booming at any point in time did you
consider just being like you know what I
don't need to do this this is worse for
me than it's better for me yeah because
like there was a time where it felt like
they're just watching you it just felt
like there was a time where you just
were like just over this [__] right
because like that whole house phone
thing happened and then that that was
the thing that bothered me is I felt
like oh this is a moment where it's
pretty obvious that
I need the guys who are hosts on the
channel to have my back during this and
like need them to help craft the
narrative that things are just fine here
and instead I felt like I kind of got
the opposite where like a lot of the
hosts on the channel were kind of like
very much actively trying to make the
situation between me and house phone
worse and he gets that now because like
me and house wouldn't have had a lot of
conversations about it and everything
and like you know he we've been talking
all day he's DJing a a show that I'm
doing on Saturday and I don't
yeah it just kind of made me realize
like there was just like a really toxic
element Brewing within no jumper at that
time and you know I don't think that any
of the hosts in particular are like
really bad people I think that they just
kind of had voices in their ears that
were probably concerned with their own
financial situation more than like the
actual long-term careers of these guys
you know so I think that there was just
too many too much [__] going on and
it's crazy because as soon as those guys
left and then we have we still have a
shitload of hosts on the channel and
like a lot of them have been really
growing and stuff and I have hosts who
literally like cannot be in the same
room I cannot have brick baby or whack
100 or you know I can't have whack 100
and [__] Mac in the room at the same
time but still like the vibe is way
better than it was before feels like as
much as that [__] kind of hurt going
through those Growing Pains
exercising that drama element out of the
business was like really important
because at a certain point it was just a
lot of people were like coming into no
jumper basically like stirring [__] up
and then going home to their streams and
making tons of content about it and that
just became like the norm every day and
that's why I felt like I needed to take
steps like moving around people on
podcasts and stuff like that because it
was just becoming really really
overwhelming I saw uh ad said something
because you had Snoopy badass on yeah
who you want special treatment because
uh Snoopy badass had a video where he
basically said that like and this was a
long time ago because I did an interview
with Snoopy like two years ago and A.D
wasn't there or anything and like Snoop
and Snoopy had a video where it
basically said that ad was blocking him
from going on no jumper and that ad is
just a hater because you know Snoopy's
the real king of Compton or whatever the
[__] he said so when I had Snoopy on the
other day I asked him what was up with
that video are you saying that you would
KD up or whatever and I guess you know
A.D like last night did this whole song
and dance acting like the victim acting
like oh that's so [__] up that I would
ask this dude about him
um so just for the record I am one of
the greatest hip-hop podcasters to ever
live and if you think that I'm gonna
have a [__] on the show and not
ask him about the beef that he
previously had with someone who was a
host on the channel
a you're not paying attention to what
I've been doing for all these years
because that is 100 what I do if I have
an interview with a rapper that hates
bootleg Kev tomorrow I'm gonna probably
make it clear in the course of the
interview like I [__] would be like Kev
but I'm gonna say so why do you hate
yeah that's normal that's what everybody
does AD like I don't know why he like
thinks he needs like special treatment
but I think the reality is is that he
probably isn't even actually bothered by
what I said in the interview with Snoopy
badass he just does like four streams a
week and he needs topics and he needs
stuff to talk about and so that probably
seemed like something that would be good
click bait right and that's not like
people just you see people become this
weird version of themselves and they
start faking fights and they start
faking beefs and they start you know
creating beef sudden nothing or whatever
and it's like
I don't know like I saw like a two
minute clip of his stream in the Reddit
and I just didn't even
I didn't even think about responding it
just seems so I was gonna say I think he
said that you guys were like cordial
we've had some text conversations since
then and everything but like okay why do
we have a text conversation when I was
in Florence about to get married is
because his cousin came on one of the no
jumper panels
and then ad did a whole stream talking
about you know if I'm not [__] with
Adam then you or if you're my cousin you
shouldn't go on no jumper or whatever
and I hit him up I sent him like you
know a couple of texts just being like
bro I didn't know you had a problem with
this [__] guy like like what do you
like but again it's like
he needed some click bait he needed
something to talk about that week so you
see how A.D even being who he is he just
is I don't know it's like weird like oh
you could have just texted me and said
like why'd you interview my cousin
instead you do a three-hour live stream
about it and you know that but that's
why I kind of feel bad for these guys
because it's like they they feel like
they have to talk about me to get views
and to get people to pay attention
because that's
all of their most viral content has just
been talking well I think Lush said that
I think Lush is like this is what y'all
want so I'm gonna keep doing it Lush did
a whole video swearing that he wasn't
going to talk about me anymore and
thanking me for the positive impact on
his career and everything and then he
interviews somebody else that I don't
[__] with and he said like hey I really
tried to stop talking about no jumper
but this is what y'all want but you guys
don't watch my [__] unless I talk about
no jumper so I'm talking about no jumper
now the difference between Lush talking
about a no jumper and not talking about
November is he'll get like a thousand
views on an average stream and then
he'll talk about his jumper and I'll get
like ten thousand Okay so
yes that is a 10x multiplier but still
you're a grown ass man getting 10 000
views on your live stream have you guys
chatted at all I mean he tries to hit me
up and stuff and it's like bro I just
don't [__] with it because I I like you
know I had him on and uh he went on he
went off on me on some [__] podcast
and then I ended up bringing him on and
we're you know we're cool because I
think I called I I called him some [__]
when you and I because I I never was
like a fan of him on the channel but
when I met him I was like oh he seems
like a really genuinely like like nice
dude and and with him it's like it just
reminds me like do not operate your
business like a [__] charity project
because he was somebody that was just so
obviously [__] and like I put him on
the channel because it was like I
thought that that was kind of like an
interesting narrative like look at this
guy he's an ex-junkie he's [__]
addicted to banging prostitutes on fig
he's just got like a clearly got a few
screws loose he's chasing this battle
rap dream but then you know like we
brought him on the channel and it's just
like everybody on the channel was just
viciously clowning him all the time and
I was the one telling people I was the
one sitting down with Almighty suspects
and saying like suspect you got to go
easy on Lush you can't just like be this
mean to him because like I remember
there was like a free freestyle thing
with a lush wrapped and suspect was
laughing so hard like falling out of his
chair and it was so funny and I'm over
here I'm the one looking out for lunch
saying suspect you can't treat him like
that like suspect you got to be nicer to
him whatever T Rell was [__] [__]
on him left and right he [__] hated
him and I'm kind of trying to like you
know navigate that and and you know like
why was I going out of my way to help
this guy I never did one bad thing to
this guy and then of course all of his
streams are about me because I'm the
only successful person that he's ever
been around in his entire life I'm the
only famous person that he's ever been
associated with so he has to talk about
me or else nothing's ever going to move
my challenge to all of those guys and
I've said this before is get a million
views
have an opinion have a thought are you
talking about on a specific video make a
video that gets a million views have a
thought have an opinion do something
the stipulations are
if you can't get a million views talking
about me that's not going to do it
there's not a million people who care
that much about any of these exos
talking about me or you know uh get an
interview talk to somebody who's like
really interesting and get a million
views that's my challenge to every
single one of them well I think you will
have proven to me that you successfully
left the nest when you get a million
views because I could tell you that last
month I got 50 million views on my
YouTube channel and this is like people
talk about a sinking ship all of these
channels combined are maybe 10 of the
views that I get in a month
and I'm a sinking ship this is what
these people actually want you to
believe it's [__] narrative they
were never mistreated while they were on
the channel I was always transparent
about pay I was always like very uh you
know open to having discussions about
what the future of the channel was going
to be so that that is the one thing that
really bothers me is just this [__]
victim narrative that was painted on the
way out but I don't think the people are
falling for it anymore I you know the
channel is doing way way better we're
crushing it right now
um and I have tons more great ideas and
at the end of the day
you need money to go to war and I got a
lot of it and I can't I mean I don't
think they want to I mean I I would hate
to see like a ward I mean obviously to
me it's like there's a scoreboard right
and I'm way up even though people tried
to paint me as if I was way down yeah I
mean but I do think it's important to
acknowledge like
community and and and back on fig are
are successful they're not maybe there's
no jumper successful but thank you I
think you've you have a head start you
know true you've been and I'm a goat I
mean look yeah of course you're you have
some of the most iconic interviews of
all time listen I think you got to look
at it as like through the scope of like
these guys just started these channels
so it's like you know but they need to
get a million views you know have you
watched uh fig Community world no no you
never well I've seen some clips here
yeah
yeah I just think that like they're
building something that they're you know
and I just wish that there was less like
like I didn't like the way the whole
split happen you know what I'm saying
um yeah it was [__] but I I think
that uh
you know both things can be true
they're successful
maybe not as successful as you but again
you have a head start but they're doing
I'm sure they're making much more money
for their families for themselves than
would you acknowledge that that they're
probably making more money now than they
were making with no jumper hell no you
don't think so no no no no no okay so
I'm not
so I just know that they have sponsors
they got you know they got their own
sponsor money coming in like I don't
know I just I just feel like they're
probably and they might be okay even if
it's even if they're making 75 of what
they were making with you oh hell no you
don't think so no I mean I listen a lot
of people talk to me a lot of people
tell me things
I basically know like almost exactly how
much money they make
and I feel bad that they had bad
management that led them in the
direction of walking away from you know
money that could do was very very
meaningful for an opportunity that
realistically has not panned out yet and
well I mean yeah I mean do you think um
there would ever be
an opportunity for you guys to do a
reunion show
or go on each other's Platforms in the
future is that out of the realm of
possibility
for me I'm looking towards the future
so is it possible I guess anything is
possible but
I just got a lot of good things going
for me right now I'm really focused on
and I don't really feel the need to sort
of go back in time you know and
obviously you know shout out to Brick
baby brick babies big baby amazing why
be better and break baby better be be
better
yo what is it about like you and gang
members where you just you just said
track yourself to La gang members like a
[__] they love me what can I say I
don't know there's just La gang members
around you at all times listen I don't
know you get in where you fit in and
I've always been a fan of this of this
music and uh at a certain point you know
like
I like having conversations with whack
100 I like having conversations with
baby
I do a podcast with Danny Mullen he's a
community Lord he doesn't even know what
who blue face is there's been multiple
times that I've mentioned blueface he
doesn't know who I'm talking about I
like doing that kind of content But
ultimately like the only people who are
going to really know a lot about the
music that I'm into are pretty much gang
members or people who are equally as
fascinated by that kind of stuff as me
so so yeah I don't know this is kind of
where I've ended up yeah because I'm
thinking let's see your two main
co-hosts now are whack and brick baby
right enemies can't be around each other
that's I gotta make it I gotta work
through this in time yeah and I mean
even back in the day it was like you had
Tyrell and you had you know so it's like
they couldn't be in the same place at
the same time is that a conversation
you've tried to uh you know mend a
little or is it even with [__] McIntyre
with whack and uh with whack and
Brickman I think like actually when I
first started the whack podcast there
was a chance that they were going to be
able to be cool and then it got way
worse after that so at this time
probably not I do think like based on
statements that they both made that if
they were to see each other that it
would not turn physical right at least
based on what they've said which that to
me is a big step big step
um but yeah I would love to get them on
the same page I think they would be
incredible together on camera but we're
not quite there yet I remember in the
past you had said that you would
interview six nine
I think I would now I was gonna say yeah
I don't know why but I got a feeling
it's coming you know my dedication to
the street code was so strong at a
certain time that it just kind of
blinded me and now I'm like I could do
it but at the same time it's like I
don't know six and I wanna sit down with
me when like I'm sure if he was watching
my commentary on the sick on the uh
Kodak Black six nine collab that he
probably would be like well [__] this
guy because like you know I wasn't
exactly positive about it but I think
with you and wax Dynamic like whack
would probably want to make that happen
right I would like to make it happen me
and whack talked about it he facetimed
me the other day with six nine and six
nine just started saying some random
[__] and I don't know I mean I would be
I would be cool it would be like
interesting because of the fact that I
was around six nine like in the very
very infancy of his career before he had
20 000 followers when I met him and I've
kind of seen him get to be the biggest
rapper in the game and now I guess he's
the biggest Latin artist in the game or
something he's definitely not that well
he's he's up there there's Bad Bunny
there's yeah peso pluma he's out there
but I don't I don't know I mean he's
doing his thing I don't think he's a bad
guy I just think he you know ended up in
a weird situation do you feel like more
now than ever The Selective outrage
about snitching is like at an all-time
high
I mean yeah Shadow whack 100 but black
always says selective politicking right
he's the most he's the selective
politician selected one
um yeah I mean definitely I mean because
I think I like the the [__] with the QC
guy you know and it's like
I mean a lot of guys are saying to him a
lot of people yeah and I and I thought
when I saw that Story come out I'm like
God damn like are there are there
certain people that aren't going to want
to be around pee anymore just went away
nobody cared yeah it just kept it moving
yeah because he didn't tell on anybody
famous
if you snitch on Young Thug you're in
trouble if you snitch on if or if people
already kind of hate you like six nine
he told on all these real gang members
who were dying to find something no
everybody wanted to tear him down it's
almost like people wanted to tear you
down and they got that little Slither
Bingo and they were like we're that and
I think that is part of why I have
empathy for six nine now having kind of
like I mean I've lived through a few
times I guess really but like you know
just seeing how bad the pylon is and
everything and I mean what if somebody
I'm not in the streets like that if
somebody snitches it's not really my
business I really don't give a [__]
there's nothing to do with me I see Vlad
interview snitches all the time doing
all kinds of crazy leg work trying to
like explain why snitches is not big
deal or whatever in their interviews and
is what it is
um hey let's stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good Folks
at King Palm that's right man shout out
to King Palm uh we're talking about
nothing but that organic all right that
natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg Kev try either one of those I
forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
disgray of course
no doctor's appointments no going and
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right bluetooth.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're gonna give you a
month's supply for free just five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview back to the Atlanta thing like
uh for you you've had so many random
people speak about this situation
we talked about Andrew Tate did Mike
Tyson say something I thought I know of
but but that is how crazy my life is
right now is that Mike Tyson could have
said something about it and I would not
know I was gonna say what's like the one
thing where you saw like oh wait this
person is talking about this this is
kind of crazy I mean yeah like Andrew
Tate talking to Tucker Carlson about it
and Tucker Carlson doing that you know
that face he's always making he's like
oh really yeah he let a man sleep with
his wife whoa like like I don't know
that that was insane because that's kind
of like two of the biggest voices on the
right I guess watching Logan Paul talk
about it the other day kind of tripped
me out just I mean he was giving you
props for your like mental fortitude
yeah and uh I thought that was pretty
cool because you seem extremely unfazed
by a lot of this yeah I'm pretty my
heart is is cold yeah I mean I'm sure
you wouldn't have done this unless you
knew you could fully like
go to sleep at night without any yeah I
mean at this point in terms of how I
view myself as a public figure it's just
I'm really not scared of the smoke I
think that there was a time period after
like those dudes left the channel where
I really didn't I just didn't want a
beef I didn't want to fight I didn't
want to like I just I was just really
turned off to like all the drama and
stuff and then having gone through the
great cooking of 2023 and the result the
resulting media storm like even just the
[__] that I just said about those dudes
I mean I'm holding back like crazy
there's so much stuff I could say but
why not like what am I scared of that
they're going to do another [__]
stream talking about me for the 1800th
time like I really don't give a [__] and
uh anybody could say anything they want
about me and I'm not really tripping
about it you know academics probably did
like 10 hours of live streaming about
the Leno thing did you watch his uh live
his live commentary I never saw any of
it he actually what's weird with him is
that he said
he texted me he's like just so you know
I'm not going to talk about the Lena
thing this is like right when it first
came out and I'm like I'm like you could
talk about it like go crazy bro I don't
[__] care he's like he's like well
it's your baby mama yada yada like I
feel like I'll be respectful and not
talk about it I'm like you don't have to
worry like you could talk about it it's
all good hey shout out to him no for
doing that but then his commentary like
I didn't see it but like I heard I just
kept hearing like reviews of it from
people and uh it's some of it seemed
kind of crazy the one thing I got mad
about is I'm like don't put my kid in
the thumbnail
which to me seems obvious but that's
super obvious keep the kid out of it his
[__] twitch mods or whoever they I
guess they were the ones who did it so
yeah I'm sure he's not on Photoshop
making the thumbnail which makes sense
yeah yeah uh you mentioned that your
wife had a number and it hit 50x yeah
can you give us any sort of idea no
because we always say well how much how
much does the number have to be for it
to be worth a hypothetical situation for
somebody to [__] my wife or you know
another person's girlfriend yeah is it
like north of 10 million
I shall not comment I can't like I would
love to just fully there's a bow just
hit you with the number my girl is very
uh
stand office about talking about
finances and [__] like she just doesn't
really want to put a dollar amount and
is this fall under the LLC that you're a
part of the money that comes in for this
like do you get your cut of that because
it is your wife uh not sorry no yeah
yeah I thought about that at a certain
point but I was like you know what like
we participated in so many different
deals together or whatever like her her
whole thing is only fans from her
account and then the plug talk accounts
uh you know I let her have her side of
things but I can say like even just for
myself that okay I had the biggest month
ever on Snapchat I believe like that any
channel has ever had at least like the
guy that handles our Snapchat like yeah
you plugged me would have shout to Dean
shout out Dean I put I put he he
basically told me that I made the most
money that of anybody he had ever seen
on Snapchat from that just from talking
about it plug talk literally doubled it
was already a great business it doubled
which that was also kind of insane for
me to see so I can't say that you know I
could say that like even just me talking
about it and the things that came from
the media storm has been insane from my
perspective from her perspective it's
even more insane it's the best-selling
only fan scene of all time
because well she so she was selling it
like you had to prepare to pay five
bucks for her only fans and you have to
pay 20 through the DMS in order to
purchase it wow
do you know what what her subscriber
count is
it is I think like five times the most
that it ever was before but I probably
said the exact number well you can't see
that if you go to the page I'm not too
like no you could see it on her end but
you can't see it oh I didn't know
because you know a [__] Instagram or
something you can see you know I don't
know if it shows that no so it's boom
business is booming business is booming
I want to get real quick before before
we wrap I think that like uh one thing
that you said when all this [__] was
like going left was like if you take
YouTube Revenue out of your uh business
model just like on some content creator
[__] like kind of give me like a little
peek into what the business of no jumper
is and like how you're able to monetize
on so many levels you mentioned the
Snapchat show Snapchat Facebook patreon
on the uh the monetization of the audio
on a you know any app where you listen
to Just the audio and it inserts ads
into it brand deals merchandise
um you know obviously plug talk is its
own [__] world uh uh
yeah there's just there's a lot that's
why I was crazy when people are like oh
like his business is done because these
hosts left I'm like maybe
I'm Gonna Make You Know
twenty thousand dollars less this month
maybe 30 000 less this month because all
these hosts left that means nothing to
me that is nothing I could gladly throw
twenty thousand dollars in the trash
every single month and it would mean
nothing to me my my mortgage on the
space is like 20 grand a month and that
means nothing to me so it's like people
really got me [__] up financially
sometimes and I guess I I kind of asked
for it because I don't flex or like do
it no you've been flexing lately but not
really right like you never see me buy
anything you never see me well I just
mean like you threw up the numbers I
mean you put the fist over the the
dollar amount for YouTube but you know
yeah I'll do the view count I'm not I'm
not telling people how much money we
make or whatever but yeah that's always
a weird one people were like oh no
jumpers doing bad and that's why his
wife did a porn scene with this other
guy it's like just because me and my
wife are both multi-millionaires does
not mean that we don't want to also make
many many more millions of dollars you
know of course like for me I look at my
life all the time and I have like
basically like two different versions of
it it's like there's the version of my
life right now where I'm working my ass
off trying to make as much money as
possible and then I have this other
version that's like well what if I just
went into chill mode and only made money
off of my more passive revenue streams
like to put it in perspective just from
selling Instagram promo
I could easily yeah the IG is its own
Beast I could have my own my entire life
paid for my kid in private school still
going on vacations from just the
Instagram promo
think about that that is a tiny
percentage
still enough to keep everything afloat
and when I was going through all that
[__] I did like think about that like
well maybe I'd be happier if I just did
whatever the [__] I wanted to do all the
time I remember I was doing a podcast
with uh Ryan long as a comedian in New
York and I said something about like how
lately yeah I've just been thinking like
maybe I just want to like you know spend
more time with the family and spend more
time around my kid if he he laughed in
my face and he goes he's like a guy like
you like you're not what are you gonna
do just sit around and watch your kid
grow up he's like laughing in my face
and I was like
yeah you're right yeah like how the [__]
I can't chill out like yeah like maybe
when I'm older or like you know I
respect the [__] out of it when I see my
girl able to sit around the house for 12
hours all day and do nothing but play
with blocks with the kid and right take
it for a walk around the block and all
that and
when I do have days where it's just me
at the house I force myself to be as
present as possible keep the phone on do
not disturb try not to be sending text
to people right about content all the
[__] time trying not to look at Tick
Tock and Twitter and all this [__] but
it's like
you know I'm still in my moment I'm
still like I have content I want to make
I have things I want to do with my life
sometimes the the hard part is that
there's just too many things I want to
do in my life I want to go play in all
these [__] Pokemon so you're a
[__] poker Beast yeah I want to go
playing all these poker tournaments that
are like twenty thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars to enter these
tournaments and [__] but it just doesn't
make sense for me to take my time and
and spend doing those things when I
could be in the office grinding out uh
content I'm gonna say how Hands-On are
you with what we see like are you like
hey we just did this interview make sure
you clip this this this and this or do
your editors send the title hey this is
the title do approve or disapprove I do
an interview and then by the end of the
day one of the guys sends me a big email
with the time stamps and suggested clips
and then I sit down did it last night I
did a [__] load of this [__] last night
for like an hour before I went to bed
where I just sat down I approved or
denied every single title uh for the
clips wrote the full title
starred things that would be like a good
Tick-Tock moment or whatever you're like
you're [__] I'm very Hands-On because
I don't think you know and now like
shout out Remo I have Remo in my life
who like helps me write questions for
some of the interviews helps me with
titles sometimes so to even have one
person that you really trust with that
kind of stuff is amazing but at the same
time like I could definitely take the
five or ten minutes to review the time
stamps that he sends through so I can
approve it or not because that's yeah
that's just one thing where it's just
like I know how I want my [__] to be
clipped and then you uh you stopped
going live right there's no more like
like when you do the wins or the no
jumper show it's not live anymore is
there a reason why you you stopped that
the number one reason is that we were
doing the live thing at 6 PM which I've
just become more and more aware of like
my own body in my own mind yeah that's
late that's late yeah it's like by the
time 6 p.m you get home at like 8 45 9
o'clock like yeah and a lot of my
interviews that I'm doing are early in
the week so it's like I might sit down
and do three interviews throughout the
course of the day on Tuesday and then
also a streaming have to have the energy
to have a really great conversation for
two hours at six pm at a certain point I
was like oh so if I don't go live
I can have a better chance of getting
the content monetized it'll be better
and have the clips ready to go and I'll
enjoy it more and it'll be better
content I think that going live is like
really good when you're still in that
period of your career where you're like
trying to you know activate your fan
base because you can interact you get to
Super chats going and I respect the [__]
out of it but I'm just not at that place
in my life where I want to be hanging
out in the studio until midnight every
night right I see fresh and fit do it I
see [__] whatever do it and I just
don't I don't know for me it just makes
more sense to record the [__] in advance
I could do all my interviews live but
then you know something like the wag 100
podcast it's like I'm paying him out a
percentage of what we make and it's like
if we do it live and it earns a hundred
dollars as opposed to us doing it in
advance and being able to cut the swears
out of the beginning and do all that and
it makes you know many many thousands of
dollars
for somebody like him it's like what am
I going to tell him like hey you didn't
make this much that much of this month
but it's because we went live like that
just would seem insane to me so that's
your deal with whack is she just said
Revenue split yeah we're Partners on
this on these videos You'll see truthful
transparency this is what the videos
made that's what you made type [__]
incentivize somebody like him and I
don't mind doing that you know we make
up we make the money in other ways I was
gonna say you did start editing out
curse words for the first couple of
minutes I was gonna say at what minute
point is the cut off because I've I've
started out my guys do like the first
five minutes just to be safe yeah but
then sometimes it's like you'll
interview somebody who says the n-word
at the end of every sentence and they
cut that out like it just really sounds
crazy I don't know we try to like hit a
good balance with it but I never tell
the person like try not to swear for the
first couple and I talk about so much
mushroom [__] on the [__] podcast so
like anytime we have like a dope shroom
clip I just know it's gonna get the
yellow [__] dollar sign I didn't even
think about that yeah there's been a few
episodes like I got a Rampage Jackson
interview it was so good and I just was
never able to get it to turn green for
like three weeks how many like how many
could you will you do the same thing we
do when we'll put up a version and then
it hits yellow [__] re-upload let's redo
this over and over and over yeah but
that that Rampage one I don't know what
it was I think he said [__] or like
[__] I think those if you want he I
think he was saying those words one of
those words a few times I was never able
to get it monetized and it's kind of
like not that big a deal like you're
talking about a couple thousand bucks
but it's like
you know it's like well that's my money
that I was supposed to make for that day
when I went in and sat down for a couple
hours I remember my house flooded the
night before the Rampage Jackson
interview and that really stood out to
me extra like I felt like I deserved to
get paid for it because I had been like
hitting water yeah yeah I've been
bucketing water out of my [__] living
room earlier in the day that really
seemed like I deserve to get paid for
what I did the next day but you know
whatever yeah not it's definitely a
struggle YouTube like you guys are on a
rumble yet huh
we made an account because we had a
YouTube strike so we couldn't upload for
a week and so we did make a rumble
account but we haven't really stayed up
on it as far as I know yeah no I I I was
was like I was like I wonder if rumble's
gonna really
take because they've been spending so
much [__] money between the kick and
the rumbles like I try to be audience
first you know yeah and that's where
YouTube is where the audience is exactly
and it's like you know maybe if somebody
said hey we're going to give you an
extra 200 Grand a month to just stream
your [__] on Rumble like well okay that
does sound kind of appealing but like
especially in the position that I'm kind
of in where a bunch of the hosts just
left it's like you want to make you want
to make the experience as easy as
possible on your fans and I don't know
it's like like I I've gotten those
offers before of like caffeine and all
this [__] and it's like you really think
that I'm just like gonna just completely
[__] over my fans just to just to get a
little extra money it's like I can make
money in other ways like I would rather
just go live on the platform that built
Us in the first place you know I feel
like uh you're overdue for a Rogan
interview is that ever almost happened
so the Rogan narrative is that one day
Rogan was in the airport which is kind
of interesting this is like 2018 maybe
um he's in the airport which I would
assume he mostly flies private he
doesn't seem like the kind of guy who
should be just hopping on a plane right
it seems like it also seems like kind of
like a normal dude yeah but also it's
just like damn imagine how [__]
annoying it is to be in the airport
dude insane I've heard I've heard about
him like trying to go work out in the
hotel lobby or not in the lobby but in
the hotel gym the dude's just watching
him and they have to like shut the gym
down because it's like every person in
there is a potential Joe Rogan fan
especially at the gym especially at the
gym but so he's in the airport and some
fan of mine who I can't even remember
who it was because I know it's somebody
that I actually know in real life he
goes up to him and he's on acid and he
says to Joe Rogan he says Joe
I'm on acid
but you need to do a podcast with adam22
he's the [__] yada yada and just starts
telling them about me and then I wake up
the next morning
and I first thing I see is a text from
this dude telling me about how he was on
acid and he told Joe Rogan about me at
the airport and I'm just looking at my
text like what the [__] and then I look
at Twitter boom Joe Rogan follow oh and
Joe Rogan DM saying hey I met this guy
on acid in the airport and he told me
that I should [__] with you
and I was just like wow that's amazing
dude I'm a huge fan you're you're one of
the main people that made me want to do
podcasts in the first place I really
have to thank you for like a lot of the
good things that happened in my life the
past couple years yada yada didn't
respond to that and um
sent them a couple different things over
the years of like look at this viral
moment or look at this conversation I
had that I thought you might like and he
doesn't he's never responded somebody
was talking about plug talk on his no
Bert kreischner was talking about they
talked about it a couple times on there
a couple well I only know of one but
they talked about it on uh they did the
protect your Park [__] with the like I
watch a lot of Joe Williams so see I
watch a fair amount of it no yeah but
you've been brought up on there a couple
times yeah but yeah I have no idea how
you actually get on Joe Rogan I would
gladly I think it's kind of his thing I
don't I'm not sure he has like a [__]
whatever he's interested in yeah
sometimes I see him do interviews with
people that are like really official and
I'm like oh that person's PR team
probably will line this up with old Joe
Rhodes but I'm surprised like uh has uh
I'm surprised I haven't seen Robert
Kennedy on your podcast or you try to
stay away from the politics
I think he's a Capper you think so I
listened to a whole interview with him
found him kind of impressive and then I
listened to another podcast that sort of
broke down all of his lies
I think he has a very strained
relationship with the truth and I'm not
really interested in a lot of these
people that are sort of making careers
out of you know basically casting
suspicion on the vaccine in ways that I
don't think make any [__] sense uh so
yeah I'm not really a big fan of that
guy
not a fan yeah
you might have some good things to say
but I don't really feel like he's being
honest with his audience do you think
because you're you're obviously dad had
a
big career in politics right um you grew
up a lot of people think that but well I
mean obviously it was close with the
Democratic party yeah a lot of people
think I might be in the Illuminati
because my dad was an unpaid staffer
volunteering to help out Bill Clinton
when Bill Clinton was a total [__]
nobody well I guess it was the governor
of Arkansas but right he wasn't yeah my
dad like helped out on his campaign and
uh my uncle actually got like a role
within the Clinton Administration and
managed to survive into the uh Bush
Administration
um with the same gig kept the same job
basically doing some like diplomatic
work with other countries and stuff like
that but yeah uh my dad had you know I
think my dad like pictured himself
having a longer career in politics but
then he ended up catching a Fed case
um being charged with mail fraud because
of some uh sheisty business that he was
accused of doing that he's still to this
day claims that he did not do but I
think that kind of threw a stick in the
spokes of his political aspirations well
I was going to say you I mean I grew up
a Democrat you know my family's that way
but it feels like uh politically [__] is
just kind of I don't know what's going
on no more but on both sides it's just
wild like yeah I Feel Like a Man Without
a home because I don't you know I can't
Vibe with all these [__] social
justice Warrior lunatics I can't Vibe
with like the trumpers the crazy
psychotic Trump [__] the GOP even like
[__] deranged death cult yeah
DeSantis is a wild boy like I'm good
it's just like like you said like
where's the normal dude at like where's
the middle of the road there's got to be
something that's a little bit more
middle of the road like you know I don't
really like even Biden I don't think
Biden has like crazy ideas about gender
in his head in his 90 000 year old head
but I do think he has people on his
cabinet or like working within his
administration that have insane ideas
about gender and uh you know it's kind
of unfortunate that I have to vote for
somebody who is basically being held
hostage by a lot of these crazy ass
ideas since I I don't think he's
personally really invested in it but at
the same time could I vote for Trump who
tried to steal the election shouldn't do
it no no couldn't vote for Trump no I
agree for not me I'm hoping this it's
like a I'm a vote for Cornell West the
green party
oh I like that what's his name the
Indian guy the Republican candidate he's
actually not a crazy person kind of like
him I still can't remember how to say
his name
Vivek I'm going to call him Vivek Rosh
Hashanah yeah that's not that's not that
but it's something that kind of sounds
like that I listened to like a two-hour
podcast with him the other day and I
kept thinking about you listen to the
all-in podcast yeah I actually saw the
Robert F Kennedy podcast on there and
that is what I was referring to yeah he
uh did a really good job on that episode
so that was I came away from that being
like I'm voting for this guy oh the the
Kennedy one yeah RFK oh yeah I thought
it was pretty good at first but the
vivifek Rosh Hashanah whose name I gotta
check him out I thought he had a very
good uh appearance on there so that was
but I also man voting for a republican
I've never seen it would be I've never
even thought about that in my life yeah
but it just takes the Democratic party
getting a little bit crazier and the GOP
getting a little bit more normal and I
could find myself there and also it
doesn't feel like it would be that big a
deal whereas like two white guys
admitting like in who exist in hip-hop
admitting that they've considering
voting for Republican I mean I feel like
we would have had a buzzfeed article
about us already if this was taking
place like I mean I'm gonna be honest
like I'm not voting for I mean the only
guy who I've heard is like reasonable is
the guy you just brought up I mean
unfortunately if it's DeSantis and Trump
or one of them too versus Biden I'm just
gonna have to vote for sleepy Joe again
I'm really honestly probably going to
vote for Cornell West I'm just going to
surrender my vote to the third party I
do think Biden has done a pretty good
job regardless of his own lack of
cognitive yeah I mean look he seems like
he's barely hanging on uh I feel like
the Afghanistan withdrawal was done in
an extremely messy and terrible way and
now China's there and it's very unstable
and uh I hate the fact that this Ukraine
war is becoming
I mean it I mean look it's pushing China
and Russia close it again I think the
Ukraine was a [__] disaster yeah but
can you imagine how bad it would have
been if Trump was the president during
it I don't know
I don't know we don't know we had a very
hard time standing up to Russia
yeah I don't know I made it to the
Sleepy Joe sleepy Joe has been gangster
as [__] he is not scared I'm waiting for
the hunter Biden podcast run whenever
he's cleared from whatever plea deal
that just fell through yeah it fell
through isn't that crazy I just got done
listening to a New York Times Daily
podcast about the deal and then to find
out the deal that they made this podcast
about him taking did not happen yeah
because he thought if he took the plea
everything it was included and the judge
was like nope poor sleepy Joe and his
crackhead son oh hey I'm not gonna lie
though
Hunter Biden looked like he was a hell
of a hang bruh this guy was having sex
parties smoking crack going 170 miles an
hour in the Nevada next track with
strangers just a wild boy leaving your
laptop at the at the like a very
Reckless one-of-one guy kind of sounds
like a lot of the people I'd be
interviewing yeah yeah like I yeah it's
like this guy should be on no jumper
with crit Mac but like I think Hunter
Biden and Tay Savage would probably get
along I don't know oh it's crazy to be
able to look I appreciate you pulling up
uh congrats on uh you know proving
everybody wrong because the Channel's
thriving you're doing well I like I love
The Wack show
we got a long ways to go but we are
going up up up to the top I love uh I
love the new host I love I mean I think
brick Bay I text brick baby because I'm
a brick baby since he was running around
with kids big baby better he's doing his
thing he'd be better and uh
yeah what's up with Flacco he's
snitching on this uh this this swiper
man I saw he put a post up saying like
if you if you got any if you essentially
if you want to tell on this guy DM me
and you know who hit me up is uh ugly
God very upset about fugly God the
rapper who apparently ugly God and punch
mate Dev have a relationship they're
friends oh which I had no idea about and
ugly God hit me up basically saying [__]
Flaco
I was like I thought this was all for
Content I didn't think because he's like
openly advocating like hit me up I'm
putting like I'm essentially if it felt
like one of those commercials you're
watching in the middle of the day for
like a class action lawsuit well because
okay so I lived through the tjx6 arc
right and I thought this was the same
thing as that because tjx6 I'm gonna be
real with you he was not really like
scamming like that like at least once he
became like having fans sending money
for like a manual yeah but he did so
much fake [__] like he had a he had a
show at a warehouse or whatever and he
had like a fake cop come and arrest him
it feels like the kind of thing you'd be
at I wasn't there but I saw the video I
wish like the kind of thing you would
have been at no yeah that was like one
of the best interviews ever like and I
remember as soon as I got in the
interview because he said a lot of stuff
that like it didn't feel like trolling
but it's like it was so absurd that I
knew he had to kind of be trolling like
he goes I'd be like when are you gonna
stop scamming I'm never gonna stop I'm
gonna do this [__] for life and I'm just
thinking in my head I'm like okay this
isn't real like this is just a dude like
it's so much [__] to go viral and then
as soon as we got done the interview he
goes over to his manager and he's just
like
crazy
crazy played but I don't even care even
care because it was great content so
like I assume when I see like punch made
Dev his video got taken down by the feds
and they're investigating him I just
assume that it's probably cap it's
probably marketing right right but maybe
it's not maybe it's the real deal I
don't know so for you like do you pull
Flacco to call him and hey what's going
on bro are we are we like
are you like snitching on this guy
because you obviously he's under your
roof actually punch me Dev tapped in
with me again about doing the interview
like we had already talked about it and
then we talked about it and then like
stopped he stopped responding for a
couple days and then Flocka went on this
campaign against him and then he tapped
in with me again like about doing it so
perhaps Flacco being an [__] or you
know a good citizen depending how you
want to look at it perhaps that is
what's going to actually make the
interview happen I don't know so that
interview might have you would you have
Flaco sit in on the interview that'd
probably be dangerous potentially
private on security in the room
definitely have to have security yeah
your security at your building you like
that [__]
crazy Tony's been in a few shootouts too
so I know that he's not scared to do it
when it comes down like yo yo you got to
sign this you gotta let me shirts like
I'm getting wanted I'm like Jesus Christ
took him to the hood with Swifty blue
the other day Swifty's a good guy yeah
but I could tell that he was maybe oh
you took your security guard with you
yeah but I could tell he was maybe a
little bit like worried about the fact
that we were just like pulling into
random that's some pretty crazy like uh
Hood Vlogs I know I wish I had like done
more of that back in the day because I
remember I did the uh stupid young Long
Beach one that was titled inside and
that was huge there are 12 million views
inside the Asian [__] gangs of Long
Beach or some [__] yeah going crazy but
I was also just like oh that was that
was cool but I wasn't like oh I got to
do it again whereas now when I think
about it you went to Watts you went to
overblock yeah I mean you went to whole
block relatively recently I was like a
year ago or something yeah it wasn't too
long ago oh yeah which seemed to be kind
of
shaky uh thing to do as a man with a
child and wife meh look let me go hang
out in old block just for the content I
had a bunch of security as a result of
the fact that I was with a 100K track so
I really felt like nothing was going to
happen but I tried to bring my own
security guard and he just didn't show
up so it was the end of that
oh he got fired yeah but you know you
live and learn do you move around with
security on a daily basis it's like if
you're going to Whole Foods
in the words of Action Bronson
why the [__] would I need a bodyguard if
you are the best when I look just like
the [__] bodyguard that's a bam
bam there it is
Adam 22 ladies and gentlemen go support
his wife's Endeavors on her only fans
thank you that means a lot go subscribe
to plug talk onlyplugtalk.com
um and then uh you know obviously go
watch no jumper man appreciate that and
uh did we talk you might have some new
[__] coming soon uh
oh we announced that today the store oh
that but then okay the thing we
announced today is we're doing a plug
talk live stream two only fans two live
streams only fans in one room YouTube
podcasts in the other room yeah so how
many dudes are gonna be a part of the
stream we have me and then we have like
three or four other guys
advocate for them not busting nuts too
early in it so that we can like preserve
their dicks any civilians or straight
porn guys uh just just porn guys for now
we're still like kind of like okay like
how long is this Gonna Last What's it
gonna be like like will a girl with nut
on her face from the only fan stream
come over and sit on the YouTube stream
possibly with DNA that is one thing that
we've been talking about is that we're
going to have one employee who is
basically positioned at the door to make
sure that there's no like dudes going on
with like their boner poking up out of
the routine yeah because you don't want
to [__] the YouTube up yeah I think jizz
on the face would probably be bad it's a
flag yeah would you
would you ever bring house phone back on
he's someone that I would be down to you
know have co-host on some podcasts and
stuff because like me and house phone
like when we've talked in recent memory
it's like what do we talk about we
talked the last time we like kind of
reconnected it was talking about punch
made Dev because me and him both the
very beginning of our friendship was
just us being really interested in all
these underground rappers and him just
sending me links and me sending them
links and stuff like that so you know I
feel like me and him on camera doors
open probably a lot more likely than
probably anybody else right for sure
well I appreciate you pulling up man
adam22 boom okay I appreciate you man
sir hey this interview is brought to you
by our good Folks at hardean all right
shout out to the Jardine family in Las
Vegas makes you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of Premium cannabis you can
ask for plus when you go to Hardy
inlasvegas.com you can check out all the
other cool stuff they got going on you
know they got a whole weed University
happening in Vegas Jardine is where it's
at all right so if you're in Las Vegas
you get into that taxi cab you say take
me to Jardin and when you get there you
tell them wonderful Bud tenders that I
sent you and they're going to take care
of you Harding underscore Las Vegas go
follow them and uh yeah we got another
interview coming soon